right my talk of the table is a
record-breaking holiday light display
north of New York City
it's raced hundreds of thousands of
dollars for great causes for our series
American wonders were exploring places
that make America wonderful for majestic
natural landscapes to spectacular
man-made creations Jamie Waxman the
family behind this spectacular show in
LaGrange Ville New York Jamie how did
this Christmas display come about
good morning Anthony it's called the ER
da JT holiday lights display which may
seem like a strange name but it's deeply
meaningful to the gay family those are
the initials of the three kids
Emily Rae Jean Daniel Arthur and John
Timothy it started more than two decades
ago with 600 lights and has grown to
over 600 thousand for the gay family the
most wonderful time of the year starts
early
every weekend starting in the fall
Tim Grace and their adult children Emily
Daniel and John get to work on their
family lights display your kids drive
long distances to come back and work
every weekend starting in September to
put this together I know my daughter's
crazy she drives from Rochester to here
every weekend that's a ten hour round
trip they pick colleges that were nearby
because they knew if they went too far
away to school they wouldn't be able to
come back and do this to be fair this
isn't any old holiday lights display
this is the Guinness world record
holding lights display for most lights
on a residential property the gay family
captured the title with six hundred and
1736 lights in 2014 could you ever have
imagined it growing into a
world-record-holding number of lights no
we did not imagine this it was not a
goal it just kind of happened
inspired by his mother's love of
Christmas Tim started putting up lights
when his daughter Emily was born 24
years ago he was showing me the two
trees in front of the house that you
started this with with 600 lights that's
how simple it started was birth of a
child
oh gosh got to start putting lights out
it was definitely motivated by that that
you know sense of wonder that I think we
all feel about life and I just wanted
that to be part of my children's
upbringing today the kids do much of the
heavy lifting contributing their own
unique talents Daniel has become
something of a lead designer what's the
most challenging display to put up or
that you've come up with the answer is
that's ornament hanging over the pie I
had a feeling that was it yeah that's
not the first thing I designed for the
display but it's the biggest most
complicated thing
John's climbing ability has helped bring
the display to new heights did you ever
think it would come in so handy no I
actually never did but uh one day just
hit us that we could put the lights
really high and it'll look pretty cool
emily has become the voice of the show
welcome to er da JT's 2-time Guinness
world record Christmas light display
[Music]
the display goes live the day after
Thanksgiving this year it features 640
1695 lights choreographed to 252 songs
but the number the family is proudest of
365,000 $781 birthday that's the amount
of money their efforts have raised for
local charities with more rolling in
each night it brings everybody together
and you know it's the time of year for
together than this
this is the first year that he's really
excited for it as we were pulling up
like now he's big enough to see it every
year they had more lights
[Music]
do you ever think that this is a giant I
love you to you from your father that I
couldn't have said it better myself
this is my dad's love to us and the
family projected immensely
the display takes thousands of human
hours to put up but the gay family tells
me they take it all down quickly in just
a couple of days after Christmas and if
you're wondering how high their electric
bill must be thanks largely to LED
lights it's only $350 a/c that's amazing
that is the most frequently asked you
worst and you were saying all everybody
in the family with the exception of the
donor or an engineer engineers it's a
family full of Engineers I think they're
the only people who could pull this off
and catalog it to the point that the
Guinness Book of World Records let's see
how many I love that the daughter said
projected love immensely yes Anthony I
thought I had the best question when you
said how do they know how many lights do
a is a very precise guy Thank You gay
family 640 one thousand three hundred
and fifty thousand dollars for charity
yeah which is that's right the most
impressive number Jamie thank you very
much
you